17 ans comme promis on revient
maintenant à cannes avant la
présentation du premier film projeté ce
soir place au glamour
la première montée des marches avec en
vedette notamment charles aznavour et
isabelle huppert
abdellah mostefa francis forget
le spectacle démarche ça se mérite et
particulièrement celui d'aujourd'hui
c'est quand même la première apparition
officielle de la présidente isabelle
huppert accompagnée de son jury et c'est
comme l'apéritif d'un festival qui va
voir défiler une pléthore de stars du
septième art
là où et à l'intérieur de l'amour
toujours standing-ovation pour isabelle
huppert
puis avec la comédienne hafsia herzi et
charles aznavour
l'annoncé officielle tant attendu fait
je déclare ouvert le 62e festival de
cannes en compétition 20 films dont
quatre français
almodovar ken loach tarantino entre
autres cette 62e édition s'annonce
alléchante
et je vous